i do kundalini yoga in the morning oh do
you with my wife i have for 20 years not
every day but i'd say
a third of the time and often for months
on end
and so and i've learned what that means
so you know when you do those yoga poses
that's not yoga
that's training for yoga it's like
imagine that you go to a dance studio
and they teach you moves that's not
dancing
dancing is what you do on the stage
after you've written your jokes
and yoga is what you do with your body
after you've mastered the poses because
it's all spontaneous and so when my wife
and i do kundalini yoga in the morning
it's a series of of flex flexion
exercises and breathing
but mostly what it is is so maybe one is
rotation of the head
like that and then
but you're paying attention it's like
okay
oh
my back hurts there okay i'll move my
head back and forth a little bit
relax move my head relax
okay it doesn't hurt anymore oh that
hurts
oh gotta explore there let that go
let that go
and you go through your whole body it's
like oh i'm cramped there oh that hurts
and what's so cool it's like massage you
know if if you're hurting and someone
massages that the pain goes away
what the hell is going on there
facilitation of
of
circulation
removal of toxins from that local but
also the drawing of your reparative
attention to that spot
well yoga is like that's like oh i'm out
of alignment there
oh i'm out of alignment there and so
what you're doing and this is akin to
stacking these chakras which is the same
as a musical experience is
imagine that
to get that process of
optimal self-revelation right
you have to be aligned
atoms aligned
with the molecules above them the
molecules
aligned in the cells the cells it
aligned in the musculature the muscles
aligned in the body the body aligned
with the environment broadly speaking
all stacked up that's the cosmic tree by
the way that's the tree the shaman climb
up and down in the psychedelic
experience that cosmic tree that unites
levels of being we can climb that with
our consciousness we do it all the time
you know if you're writing a book you
concentrate on the word or the paragraph
or the whole chapter
you know and when we're conversing i
could concentrate on each word or the
phrase or the sentence or the context or
i could look around the room
up and down these levels of analysis in
yoga you're trying to get
your body
psychophysiologically aligned so
communication between all those levels
isn't interfered with unnecessarily and
then that opens you up in some sense to
the possibility of speech emanating from
the depths that would be one way of
thinking about it one of the things that
people who do kundalini talk about is
that they are able to achieve
psychedelic states and psychedelic
states that ordinarily are achieved
through drugs
i have many friends who have done
kundalini and for whatever reason i
never have
but they have said that through it with
long-term commitment to practice they
can achieve these bizarre states where
they have hallucinations have you ever
had that
no but what i would say is that
the this process of alignment
makes everything
into the equivalent of a psychedelic
experience like everything
because
part of the manifestation of the truth
is a consequence of the alignment of
these levels
it's like that's what we mean when we
talk about someone having integrity
or being authentic it's like they're the
same all the way down and not only that
they're where they are completely so not
only are they aligned internally
they're aligned with everything that's
happening around them
and then and you know this perfectly
well but you're a master at it because
otherwise he wouldn't be where you are
the fact that you can focus your
attention almost completely
on the current conversation
means that the conversation becomes deep
and that's obviously manifesting itself
in a psychedelic way in your existence
it's like what the hell joe you're you
know
who the hell are you
you started this podcast just talking to
people zero production value you don't
edit it you talk to people for three
hours
what kind of stupid business model is
that that's insane
yeah and look what's happened
[Laughter]